jean-pierre j'ai la charge de parler
avec vous de ce grand enjeu que sont les
territoires et la ruralité enjeu majeur
vous le savez bien et je veux dire ici
que nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à
un risque considérable la loi consacre
les métropoles et nous avons aujourd'hui
dans notre pays
une perspective qui peut être sombre si
nous nous opposons pas à cette logique
qui est la métropolisation de nos
territoires
les grandes villes sont une chance pour
nous un foyer de croissance et
d'innovation
nous y sommes favorables mais c'est
aussi une grande menace pour tous les
territoires alentours qui risque
évidemment d'être dévitalisées privés de
leurs services publics privés de leurs
ressources
si nous ne sommes pas capables à partir
de nos conseils régionaux de
contrebalancer ses effets et d'offrir
une puissance de compensation et ce sera
le point clé la proposition que nous
portons dans ma région pour la ruralité
je dirais très vite car le temps est
brève nous devons rééquilibrer la
politique des transports en faveur de la
route
nos régions ont tout misé sur le rail la
route de la compétence des départements
nous le savons à nous d'aider les
départements à entretenir à développer
les routes
il n'y a pas de ruralité s'il n'y a pas
de plan routier
j'observe que le gouvernement nous dit
chaque jour sa passion de la ruralité et
j'ai dans ma région
une concurrente qui se rappelle de ce
gouvernement
auréolé de ses échecs et qui dit
elle-même sa préoccupation pour l'avenir
de la ruralité
simplement c'est ce même gouvernement
qui comme il a été dit ce matin a réduit
de 28 milliards entre 2014 et 2017
puisque c'est un projet en cours a
réduit de 28 milliards
les dotations aux collectivités
territoriales on ne peut pas dire une
chose et faire son contraire c'est le
même gouvernement
c'est le même gouvernement qui favorise
la métropolisation au détriment des
territoires ruraux et dans ma région
c'est la même majorité qui lie sa
passion pour le monde rural et
l'agriculture et qui entre 2008 et 2015
a réduit de 32%
le budget dédié à l'agriculture et à la
ruralité
on ne peut pas dire une chose et faire
son contraire ce que nous devons offrir
à nos territoires
outre la route c'est l'accès aux soins
sujet majeur qui vient d'en parler il
faudra être capable d'offrir à tous nos
concitoyens un accès aux soins rapides
la sécurité j'ai pour ma part proposé
dès le 1er septembre que la région
prenne sa part dans la sécurité des
personnes et des biens en particulier
pour aider les communes rurales qui sont
sans moyens est exposé à des problèmes
de délinquance ou d'insécurité pour les
aider à trouver les réponses appropriées
et s'il le faut aller cofinancer
il me paraît aussi nécessaire de
développer les antennes universitaires
délocaliser dans les villes moyennes
pour des raisons à la fois académique et
social cela permet aux ménages dans des
revenus modestes de voir leurs enfants
accéder à l'université sans avoir à
quitter la ville où ils sont c'est à
dire sans avoir à dépenser un argent
qu'ils n'ont pas je voudrais aussi vous
dire et j'insisterai sur ce point qu'il
n'y a pas de ruralité s'il n'y a pas de
rire culteurs je ne prendrai qu'un cas
vous avez raison vous avez raison de les
applaudir
je prendrai un cas qui est un grand
sujet et j'aimerais qu'ensemble nous
ayons la capacité sur ce grand dossier
d'avancer dans notre territoire nous
devons mes chers amis engagé de grands
programmes de construction de retenues
d'eau dans nos territoires
c'est essentiel c'est essentiel
cela paraît technique mais c'est
essentiel et nous avons tous et c'est
dans ma région
nous avons tous en mémoire cet événement
terrible
cet échec total de la puissance publique
des procédures les plus accomplis qui
toutes ont été tenus en échec par une
poignée d'opposants sans compétence sans
connaissances qui ont empêché la
construction du barrage de sivens c'est
d'une très grande gravité
nous devons être capables de construire
un grand programme de retenue d'eau
sachez que nos paysans l'attendent
impatiemment pour que vous ayez ces
informations est importante
d'ici 2030 le rive le niveau de nos
rivières en tout cas dans ma région aura
baissé de 50%
c'est un sujet vital il n'ya pas d'autre
mot je terminerai en disant deux choses
d'abord ne laissons pas nos territoires
ruraux au front national la semaine un
grand combat
la semaine un grand combat et vous le
savez vous le savez le front national je
ne parle pas de ces électeurs c'est à
nous de les convaincre de revenir à nous
de leur dire qu'ils se sont trompés ou
qu'on les a trompés nollet stigmatisons
pas donnant l'heure des raisons de voter
à nouveau pour nous de les convaincre de
venir vers nous c'est ainsi qu'il faut
faire mais je voudrais vous dire nous ne
disons pas suffisamment que le front
national n'est qu'un cartel familiale
dans le bonheur privé est indexé sur le
malheur de notre beau pays
c'est inacceptable et je finis vraiment
je finis vraiment en vous disant d'où je
viens
moi qui suis entré si récemment en
politique j'ai été investi par ce parti
le 7 mai 2015
jallet prouve une grande fierté je les
dis je le redis ici je vous redis ma
reconnaissance
j'en éprouve une grande fierté je me
suis engagé je me suis engagé au terme
d'une réflexion qui a été précipitée par
un échange avec notre président j'étais
dans son bureau je vous raconte
laissez moi vous raconter c'est très
court j'étais dans son bureau
nous étions tous les deux nous
discutions de la marche du pays et je
lui ai dit mon point de vue il me
faisait valoir le sien et à en donner
une matière en équipe
la différence entre toi et moi c'est que
moi je suis un homme d'action
toi tu es un homme de réflexion cette
phrase m'a beaucoup marqué elle m'a
beaucoup marqué cette phrase m'a marqué
et m'a déterminé en m'engage à m'engager
auprès de vous avec vous j'en suis très
fier j'ai reçu des encouragements de
nicolas sarkozy ses félicitations au fur
et à mesure que nous avancions dans la
campagne
je veux vous dire ici et je peux le
rendre public
cher nicolas dans ton bureau j'ai pris
un engagement auprès de toi je le dis
aujourd'hui j'ai dit cette région est
jugée imprenable je veux la prendre je
la veux je la veux me collard
je veux colorés en bleu je veux coloré
ample cette région qui est rouge depuis
si longtemps
c'est mon engagement je m'y tiendrai
c'est ça mon engagement je m'emploie
tous les jours mes amis allez on gagne
tous les jours je m'emploie à prendre
cette région je la veux nous n'aurons
nicolas cette région je veux la prendre
comme toutes les autres
les 6 et 13 décembre prochain on va
gagner partout même chez moi
allez la victoire